sommes-nous en train d'assister à un
immense fiasco l'année dernière à
travers une story Kev Adams se propose
aux internautes de participer au
financement d'un film d'animation en
achetant des NFC des personnages du
long-métrage crédit nounours digital
plus de 1200 euros
ça vous permet d'avoir une vraie part de
production du film un projet ambitieux
pour un film au casting plutôt alléchant
rapidement relayé par de nombreuses
célébrités
mais alors qu'il devait voir le jour en
2023 le long-métrage est aujourd'hui au
point mort d'après une enquête publiée
par Mediapart plus de 700 personnes
affirment avoir perdu leur
investissement et n'avoir obtenu que
quelques goodies aujourd'hui on peut
dire que j'ai payé 2250 euros voilà
alors cette histoire voilà après oui
Guillaume c'est une histoire de fou en
gros ils ont demandé à des gens
d'investir d'acheter ce qu'on appelle
dnfc donc c'est des petites figurines
des petits dessins qui valaient 1250
euros chacun en leur permettant d'être
producteurs du film eux ils espéraient
lever jusqu'à 70 millions d'euros
c'était le budget du film
malheureusement ils ont levé qu'un
million cinq donc 70 millions d'euros le
budget du film n'est pas appétit 70
millions d'euros c'est pas possible il
voulait 70 millions d'euros c'est plus
qu'Astérix si vous voulez faire une
super production internationale
ils ont levé qu'un million cinq d'accord
donc première question comment Kev Adams
et tous les artistes autour parce qu'il
y a plein d'artistes pas du tout les
arnaqueurs
ont prêté leur voix aussi ils se sont
ils se sont fait embrouiller par un
producteur un peu véreux qui leur a dit
voilà c'est le coup de l'année dernière
et deuxièmement parce qu'ils sont dit
qu'ils allaient que tout le monde allait
gagner énormément il voulait faire un
blockbuster mondial comme Toy Story
comme voilà et deuxième question où est
l'argent parce qu'il y a donc 700
personnes des anonymes qui ont payé des
nounours 1250 euros il y en a un qui ont
investi
et le producteur il se défend en disant
mais les gars en fait moi j'ai payé des
influenceurs américains parce qu'il
voulait développer le truc à
l'international j'ai donné un million
500000 euros donc aujourd'hui il y a
plus rien et les NFC on va pas se mentir
ça c'est un peu casser la gueule et non
ce qui va les 1500 euros 1200 euros il y
a un an il valent 150 € aujourd'hui avec
l'argent qui rembourse les gens
rembourse pas les gens parce que ils ont
été ils ont été pris comme des
producteurs associés et donc du coup ils
ont investi en même temps quand le mec a
payé les influenceurs américains et bah
les producteurs laissaient sans
producteur et bah ils ont payé en même
temps via la personne en fait ils ont
été producteurs du film donc il y a
longtemps et même qu'est-ce que c'est
arnaquer la nature
tu me mets dans une sauce
Dubaï moi j'attaque sinon tu deviens
complice faut rembourser les gens non
alors disons qu'à minima il a fait
preuve de légèreté parce qu'il
promettait des rendements fois 500 c'est
à dire vous aviez si c'est 1000 c'était
500 fois plus
voilà deuxièmement
pardonnez-moi quand il lance quand il
lance le projet à côté de lui il y a
l'homme déguisé en nounours et cet homme
déguisé en nounours c'est un certain
Fabien T qui est son ami qui a financé
son anniversaire qui est un grand joueur
de poker
par Tracfin le l'organisme français qui
piste l’argent opaque donc cet homme là
il est sulfureux donc je pense que Kev
c'est
pas non plus un million
de personnes
autour de voilà après il faut pas lui
coller je sais pas moi je pense que les
deux sont embrouiller je connais aussi
Fabien Théo
ils ont voulu faire les malins ils sont
dit on va faire on va prendre de
l'oseille tout ça tout ça il y a eu des
mecs qui étaient au dessus qui les ont
dit bah tiens on a trouvé deux pigeons
on va les embrouiller et voilà
moi je pense je suis persuadé que Kev
était sûr qu'il embrouillait pas les
gens alors quel je vous le dis sur un
truc jamais il irait là-dessus si il
savait qu'il y avait une embrouille
derrière enfin si il se doutait donc
c'est pas du tout douté il s'est fait
embrouillé par des mecs voilà qui sont
libres on a trouvé deux pigeons voilà et
on va aller on va les embrouiller et on
va leur dire qu'on va faire un film de
fou à une cause super production et
d'ailleurs l'arnaque est forte on va pas
se mentir
ils ont dû faire deux rendez-vous dans
des beaux bureaux j'ai commencé ça se
passe et puis les mecs ils te font faire
n'importe quoi voilà mais on vous avait
raison c'est que dès le départ
d'ailleurs dans la vidéo il dit
attention c'est pas sûr il faudra qu'on
en vende 50 000 50000 par et très vite
deux mois après ça c'était en mer bah
tiens Fabien m'écrit là voilà il y a
aucune arnaque tu vois ça bien tu vois
tu mets ce que je pensais il y a aucune
arnaque vraiment tout est faux on a levé
un peu plus de 1,1 million cela nous a
coûté plus de 1 million six dans ma
poche issu de plus de 500000 euros de ma
poche et c'est vrai que Fabien je le
connais c'est un mec qui met de
l'oseille comme ça voilà c'est pas en
fait Fabien c'est pas un voyou je le
connaissez un mec c'est un mec voilà
c'est un mec qui aime bien il aime bien
il aime bien investir c'est un kiffeur
voilà mais c'est pas un mec qui qui tu
vas te faire un coup d'arnaque je le
connais je vous dis je le connais très
bien j'étais avec eux donc il y a aucune
arnaque voilà il a c'est vrai que étrate
fin il est sur Instagram c'est vrai
qu'il a une vie atypique parce que c'est
un joueur de poker
etc voilà donc c'est normal suivi par
traction exactement tous les joueurs de
poker mais Fabien je le connais je vous
le dis Fabien et c'est un mec voilà
c'est un mec si voilà c'est je le
connais c'est une grande gueule il aime
bien il fait kiffe la vie hein kiffeur
et voilà il s'est dit tiens pourquoi pas
faire ce projet et je vous dis que voilà
aujourd'hui bon euh ils ont ils ça leur
coûte 500000 € apparemment avec Eve je
vous dis jamais de la vie il sera allé
sur un bail comme ça si il savait que il
y avait la moindre je le connais par
cœur c'est pas du tout son délire alors
il a peur de KEF je le connais
pas
une comptabilité justement je voulais
dire Kev Adams a l'habitude ces deux
premiers films ont été financés comme ça
en participation ça s'appelle my family
sa société alors comme ça regarde ce
qu'il me dit parce que je vous dis il me
dit l'histoire et bien plus folle que tu
ne le penses qu'on Cyril si tu veux la
connaître je te le dirai c'est un vrai
thriller donc voilà apparemment ils sont
vraiment dans une sauce qu'il est
dépassent à eux aussi voilà et euh
Fabien voilà Fabien je le connais je
vous dis c'est pas un mec qui va faire
des énigmes qu'on connaît depuis des
années c'est pas un mec qui fait des
embrouilles bah oui donc moralité
arrêtez des gens faut qu'ils arrêtent
aussi de mettre de l'oseille comme ça
dans les Naft de l'oseille dans les
trucs à Dubaï dans les trucs qui voient
sur Instagram tous les gens qui mettent
de l'oseille en mettant je vais mettre
2000 euros et je vais être milliardaires
maintenant c'est triste pour ces gens là
en fait puisque le mec qui avait pas
beaucoup d'oser qui se dit je vais
mettre 2000 € et je vais mettre
milliardaires donc les gens ils se
reprennent en main et qui ce qu'ils
arrêtent de balancer leurs oseille on a
communiqué de Kev euh voilà l'instant
les amis je n'ai pas l'habitude de
répondre polémique mais là vu l'ampleur
il me paraît important de mettre les
choses au clair j'étais contacté en 2021
au sujet d'un projet de longs métrages
d'animation participatif l'idée était
simple je devais prêter ma voix un
dessin animé potentiel et d'en faire la
promotion autrement dit exercer mon
métier c'est tout le concept était
nouveau moderne cool et l'idée de
partager un film avec les gens me
plaisaient je me suis assuré du sérieux
du projet j'ai même longuement parlé
avec les studios qui étaient censés
produire et fabriquer le film j'étais en
confiance entouré de professionnel j'ai
compris par la suite que leur projet
était trop ambitieux et inadapté au
marché des NFC du cinéma je me suis
moi-même engagé pour rien je précise que
de mon côté il y a eu aucune
rémunération le principe pour moi était
d'être rémunéré uniquement si le film se
faisait je regrette que des personnes se
sentent aujourd'hui lésées ou trahis
contrairement à ce que certains articles
font croire je ne suis pas le cerveau
d'une opération d'une arnaque quelconque
j'ai juste accepté de prêter ma voix un
film d'animation et je me retrouve
aujourd'hui au coeur d'une polémique qui
remonte en cause mon intégrité et mon
honnêteté vis-à-vis de mon public
comme ça
il doit être mettre dans des sauces tu
as juste été juste passé et te mettre
dans des sauces terribles donc voilà
donc les mecs c'est encore une fois
voilà encore une fois chez ce que je dis
à chaque fois voilà encore des personnes
qui ont mal fait leur travail qui ont
voulu faire du buzz qui ont voulu mettre
Kev Adams dans la sauce parce qu'il
voulait le mettre dans la sauce et
qu'ils sont libres ça va faire un buzz
une fois de plus les mecs ne font pas
leur travail ils écrivent avant de de
faire leur travail ils mettent des
titres à color c'est devenu
insupportable je vous le dis et ne
franchement ne croyez rien de ce qui est
écrit de ce qui est dit la plupart c'est
95% de conneries pourquoi les gens nous
envolent ici parce que on reçoit des
gens qui disent parfois la vérité ou
leur vérité voilà parce que nous ici on
accepte plusieurs vérités ou bien on a 7
de se poser des questions de débattre et
de pas avoir des avis d'avoir de ne pas
avoir tous le même avis
résultats lors de du covid ça a été le
cas sur d'autres sujets voilà
aujourd'hui nous ça dérange parce que
voilà les mecs je vous avais eu la
presse les chéris on le voit bien c'est
tout si on tousse dans le même sens il y
en a pas un qui veut faire des
étincelles il y en a pas à part voilà à
part que deux trois voilà qui font des
vrais enquêtes ou des trucs comme ça
sinon c'est catastrophique et ils vont
tous dans le même sens et dès qu'il
trouve un truc c'est taper sur les uns
sur les autres mais taper sur keV Adam
c'est facile je peux vous dire voilà je
diront jamais taper sur le gouvernement
ou sur un truc vous voyez bien on l'a vu
un la réforme des retraites elle est
passée crème personne n'a rien dit dans
les journaux j'ai pas eu des gens
s'offusquer sur la réforme des retraites
ou des journalistes voilà ils font comme
d'habitude voilà c'est des c'est des
suiveurs c'est des moutons vous le savez
et voilà il essayait de faire du buzz
sur des personnes voilà qui ont rien
fait une fois de plus ils sont dit tiens
on va mettre Kev Adams ils font un
travail qui est catastrophique et ils
sont en train je vous dis de faire
beaucoup de mal au vrais journalistes et
c'est ça le problème et si j'étais les
journalistes les vraies journalistes qui
font bien leur travail je ferai vraiment
des pétitions pour arrêter tous ces
journalistes qui font de la merde et qui
sont en train de
mettre tous les journalistes dans le
même panier allez dans la rue dès que
vous arrivez avec un micro journaliste
et j'en vote pas vous parler les gens
veulent pas vous parler parce qu'ils
savent très bien que c'est que des
conneries et que de toute façon voilà il
y a très peu de gens qui prennent des
risques et qui disent leur vérité ils
disent la vérité du gouvernement ou la
vérité qu'il faut dire pour être bien vu
bon voilà comme ça ça c'est fait donc
encore une fois une connerie